today we are using linux
what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to the code review series
the series in which you guys just email
me code and i i take a look at it today
as i mentioned we are on linux
don't ask me why i decided this would be
a good idea after spending like two
hours recompiling the kernel for the
fifth time i think we finally have a
build of linux running that can
run this program that someone sent me in
my quest for diversity when it comes to
these code review videos i mean last
time we did like a university assignment
i'll have that linked up there but in my
quest to be a little bit you know
different i've decided that we're not
even going to be looking at c plus plus
code today it's going to be c c 99 to be
precise and we're not going to be
looking at it on windows we're going to
be looking at it on linux now windows is
kind of my
my my development specialty platform if
that makes sense like 90 of the
development i've done in my life has
been on windows and
for like windows and other platforms but
these days especially i'm kind of on
windows targeting windows so this is uh
this is this is going to be interesting
back when i worked at ea a lot of my
time was spent developing a mobile
engine so android and ios development so
i am pretty familiar with like the kind
of linuxc libraries and stuff like that
but that being said it was a terrible
experience developing for android and it
has been a very long time so
this is going to be a bundle of joy this
project it actually is quite interesting
i mean let's take a look at the actual
uh email that i got so this was sent to
me by pablo who does not value anonymity
it seems this is a voxel renderer that
mimics the old comanche
engine that was popular in nova lodging
in the 90s
do i look old to you i have no idea what
that is ah okay
right maximum overkill 1992. that's kind
of cool so i guess
all of this terrain is like a kind of a
voxel
algorithm situation can you please share
your opinion on this piece of code it's
a voxel engine implementation with
multiple threads the most relevant
insights i like to hear from you are
overall program structure use of threads
um cache the friendliness of this
solution does that mean like how cache
friendly it is or
i'm supposed to
cache the friendliness of the okay i'm
just gonna assume he's talking about the
cpu cache here functions are okay
whatever we'll we'll discover that for
ourselves to build and run should be
enough to run okay here is the url i
will have this linked in the description
below as always so you guys can take a
look at it be sure to be in the
multi-thread branch looks like the
multi-thread branch is the default
anyway
so yeah i mean this is a screenshot of
what it looks like pretty cool i haven't
really taken a look at anything like
this yet so i'm actually kind of excited
he did mention that it's got no
dependencies i guess uh although here
it's dependent on glfw but that's okay i
think it's gonna be pretty amazing to
take a look at this and uh see what we
can kind of discover in the source code
and see if there are any kind of tips
that i can provide as well but first
this video is sponsored by skillshare so
for those of you who don't know
skillshare is an amazing online learning
community where millions of creative and
curious people from all around the world
can come together into one place into
one awesome community to learn pretty
much any new skill you can think of like
literally anything that you are
interested in that you want to learn
more about skillshare probably has a
class for it whether you are interested
in like creative topics like photography
videography
illustrations stuff like that or you're
more interested in like business
productivity how to like run a youtube
channel and how to make good youtube
videos stuff like that skillshare has
got you covered my single most favorite
feature about skillshare is the fact
that the videos are just so concise
they're so they don't have fluff to them
they're really to the point and they
they're not very long they don't need to
be very long they're really kind of
digestible because they're just so well
made that
i mean i could probably benefit from
that let's be honest but for a limited
time skillshare is also giving the first
1000 people who click the link in the
description below a one month free trial
of skillshare premium so for free you
can take a look at skillshare's entire
catalog of videos and see if there are
any classes that you are interested in
huge thank you to skillshare as always
for sponsoring this video let's move on
and take a look at this voxel space
engine okay so i've cloned the
repository you're looking at it
there's an assets a lib's a source
folder all of this stuff now this uses
make which is pretty standard on linux
i've also opened up a terminal to this
directory now outside of this video just
to not bore everyone i've also installed
just using apt-get install glfw and also
the audio library that's being used by
this repository it's this uh so loud
thing so i've installed that on the
actual like linux computer so that i
don't have to worry about actually
downloading it for this repository
specifically the beauty of linux is the
package managers i mean i have to give
them that so now we should just do make
and it should just work which is pretty
exciting and it looks like it has in
fact worked so let's take a look at
what's happened there's a bin folder
there's a bunch of files in here which
are presumably the assets that are being
used and there's a binary file so let's
go ahead and get into that bin folder
and try and run that binary file
and we get an error error opening file
okay so two files i guess the shaders
probably tried to be opened they didn't
work i swear if someone sends me another
project that doesn't work okay so it
looks like we are gonna have to fix this
let's go ahead and open this up in
visual studio code and take a look at
presumably some kind of shader file that
couldn't be loaded now you guys can
watch how i quickly fix code that i
receive
um okay so assets share okay well
actually if we go back to this you can
see that there is no assets folder so
what if we
move everything into an assets folder
let's just quickly do this we'll move
literally everything except that also
into here let's go back to this and see
if we can run it
okay different error
syntax error unexpected exclamation mark
inside the shader code
i should probably just fast forward
through this but i'm not going to so
that you can also feel the pain i'm
going through
what is this exclamation mark in the
shader
what's going on where are the shaders
let's uh
let's go to the shaders so assets
shaders
that looks pretty standard pretty good
should probably make the font size a bit
larger okay so this vertex shader looks
pretty good to me i certainly don't see
any exclamation marks neither do i see
them here so i don't know what that
error is all about shader.c
okay let's let's see if we can print the
shader code that we're actually like
getting okay so we're reading it here
shader code let's just go ahead and
uh right before we compile it let's just
print it to see if we're actually
reading the file properly because it
does look like way it does look like
we're reading the file properly so i
don't know why this specifically isn't
working so let's go back
make is that gonna remove my assets
directory i hope not no okay so we'll
run it again
here's the shader code
ah okay look look at all this
okay so it looks like someone has
probably forgotten a null termination
character so let's take a look at this i
love the go to's
but it says i'll forgive you maybe so uh
shader code uh we read shader code yeah
okay so
this is obviously not going to read to
the plus one character which you
shouldn't assume is zero so there is no
null termination character so let's just
go ahead and quickly chuck that in there
and now
make and
main
all right it's running good
looks pretty cool actually so this is i
guess some kind of like okay it's
cycling through all of the different
uh levels here this this is pretty cool
i like taking i like taking a look at
stuff like this now since he mentioned
that this is uh obviously something that
i guess is emulating some really old
ms-dos uh engine uh i'm assuming that
none of this is
actually rendered in 3d space i think
it's probably all rendered to some kind
of texture and that's always using
opengl for just to display the texture
it's running at 120fps which also
implies that
it's probably just like software
rasterizing essentially so let's let's
actually dive in and take a look at the
code oh escape worked that's nice so the
actual kind of layout uh seems pretty uh
simple here we've got a source folder
which has all of the kind of main stuff
in it he's got a pretty nice main
function again this is c so i have to
remember that this is c and there are
certain things that we have to do like
right void here i don't know if that's
standard c99 kind of code i have written
very little actual c code that is
compiled with a c compiler not a class
plus compiler in my life so i don't even
know what is permissible and what is not
but um we're going to assume that
obviously this is uh
you have to write void here okay so
program this equals program creates a
program is some kind of struct which we
find in program.h let's quickly take a
look at that so in general i like the
kind of um
the the way that the main function is
really clean and we just kind of create
the program which probably initializes
some variables maybe sets up the windows
stuff like that we have a main loop that
we call which probably has like a while
loop in there that runs until the window
is closed and then finally we have a
destroyer to kind of just destroy
everything
and free all the memory which you know
is questionably like usable and then
he's using this as the kind of variable
name because of course this isn't a
keyword in c because there are no
classes so uh that's kind of nice as
well it kind of almost makes me makes me
it tricks me as like a c plus plus or
really as any object-oriented programmer
i think in c sharp and java it's also
like this is also a keyword that refers
to the current class instance so anyway
let's go into program create um and
actually i want to take a look at
program.h so where would that be
program.h okay we've got some nice uh
header guards here old school header
guards love this stuff
um
map type we've got you got a capital y
there bro i'm sorry that's not gonna fly
um and then we have uh okay color map
name is map count so what is map count
okay map count is just the last name
here so it's going to be the amount of
these one two three four five six we
have six of them okay so you've got
color maps and height maps so if we
actually go to the assets for a minute
this might help us decipher this so we
have like what looks like are these
color maps but then we have height maps
as well so the color map just determines
like i guess the color of each voxel so
each pixel becomes like a voxel it's not
really a voxel it's just that it's at a
certain height
like
and all of this like all this kind of
depth and height and these kinds of
words like they're all they all just get
fed into a mathematical algorithm that
actually determines where they are in 2d
space anyway because of course at the
end of the day we're simply rendering a
texture that we display on our screen so
um it's important to kind of i think
it's important to like if you're
actually curious as to how these
algorithms work and how we're able to
kind of project all of this in 3d space
don't forget that at the end of the day
you end up with a 2d coordinate of where
to place a pixel and of what color
so don't get too kind of carried away
with this so again we have like a color
map which i guess determines all this
know that the shadows are actually kind
of baked into these maps so those
shadows that we saw are not really
they're not actually calculated i
actually thought they were um they're
not actually calculated it turns out
they're actually encoded into the color
map but then the height map which will
line up with this color map you can
actually see here that you can still see
those rivers and they're in the exact
same place here this height map just
determines how high things are so how
high is each pixel here that we render
as a voxel in 3d space well in in 3d
space right so we have the black which
is a lower value like zero which is
probably like the base and that's why we
have these rivers here but then as we
get higher the value increases which
kind of makes it go more towards white
and it becomes lighter here so these
these pixels are of a higher value than
these pixels because they're brighter
which means that they will be higher
conceptually so that's kind of how these
two maps work which is kind of
interesting and again i have never
looked into engines like this before uh
in the 90s i was busy like learning to
walk and talk and do that kind of stuff
so i definitely wasn't playing these
games
and i definitely wasn't studying the
engines
so i love looking at this stuff honestly
because it's it's kind of cool it's a
blast from the past anyway back to where
we were inside programs let's go let's
go to the c file and actually kind of
take a look at this again i could spend
hours looking at this i'm sure you guys
don't want to sit through that um
although if you do let me know uh so
let's just go into program create and
see what's up so it looks like we are
high map names and stuff so we're cop so
we're doing a little string copy we're
copying that into this array that is
fine uh to do it that way i guess
again c you know c is always fun
i'm not sure why these even have to go
here i guess they get loaded at some
kind of yeah sprite create probably
loads them using an array so this kind
of just sets up that array
uh i don't really see why you couldn't
have just like assigned these cons char
pointers to the
uh to what is presumably
yeah
oh right okay because it's a
pre-allocated buffer of 50 but they're
const chars you're not going to modify
them are you because if they're cons
sharp pointers they're stored in
read-only memory which means you can
always you can obviously point to them
and they're just in a place in the
binary so there's no actual memory that
needs to be
uh like accessible during runtime and by
accessible during runtime i don't mean
accessible because obviously we can read
the read-only memory we just can't
really write to it or at least we're not
supposed to uh so like if you were to
allocate like like a good example is
like the shader code that we load during
runtime that needs to be in a kind of
dynamic place because we don't know what
the data is before we start running
whereas this stuff since these strings
are literally stored here they are just
stored in the reader in this section
which means that instead of copying them
into another place now which has a
buffer that is i need to double click on
these files so they stay open
instead of doing that which goes into a
buffer that is like 50 characters at the
most right
we don't have to do any of that we can
just store const chart pointers and not
worry about stack memory allocation
which happens here so i'm not sure why
it's done this way i probably wouldn't
do it this way these are clearly fixed
strings anyway
but
whatever so we create the graphics i'm
not going to dive into the graphics
creation too much because i don't think
that's the point of this
uh and then we oh there's this sound i
didn't even hear any sound
anyway and then we go through all the
maps and we do sprite create so what is
sprite create let me just uh i'll just
control
shift f that so here's sprite create in
sprite that uh okay uses stb image to
actually load the image data and then we
return
this which is sprite which just contains
the image data okay cool so we allocate
a buffer well sdbi will do that actually
uh which will contain
our image so we just create the images
basically now we've got them inside
height maps and color maps and then we
set some other variables again to this
which is our program which we then kind
of copy back to main
dot c
and then we pass into program main loop
so you know this is kind of uh i guess
like a structure i'm not a huge fan of
this because we are kind of creating
this program object which we then return
and then pass into everywhere passing
variables around is very common in
c-style programming i'm honestly not
even sure why they like to do it this
way i would have just stored this in
global memory in some kind of structure
so that we could just kind of access it
everywhere without having to pass it in
everywhere again it is a pretty small
program so i think that's not that big
of a deal but
like structurally that's probably
something i would have done
and then obviously passing it by value
like that is also not great because
we're kind of copying all of these
variables around for no reason so um
because we don't have references in c
you would use a pointer uh and then
actually pass it in like that and that
would just be something that would be a
little bit better
um again you know not a huge deal we're
not calling mainly preparedly we're not
copying masses amount of data repeatedly
and doing like heap allocations through
copy constructors because there's none
of that here but it's still something
that i probably would do just
as a habit
okay and then we have p thread in for p
threads and we have these p thread
counts so we have um he did mention this
was multi-threaded of course we have
seven threads it looks like and these
seven threads so i'm probably going to
focus in on the threads in this video
because we haven't really talked about
multi-threading before too much in this
code review series and i
you know how long have i been recording
for this video is probably way too long
already i always these videos always end
up being so long um but anyway uh i'm
just going to focus in on that aspect of
things and then we'll kind of brush
everything else aside so what do we do
here so we create seven threads with p
thread info what is p thread info uh let
me try and find that that might be like
in the header file uh what is that
program.h
uh okay here's p thread in first so we
have an actual p thread which is just
like a unix kind of linux style
uh uh thread it's i guess the equivalent
of whatever win32 threads would be which
i don't know i mean in c plus plus you
would use sd thread and then behind the
scenes it would it would probably be a p
thread on like posix platforms but
anyway so we have the actual thread
right i wouldn't probably call it
handler but we have the actual kind of
thread um and then we have stock column
and column oh yeah i assume this is just
for image data so what this is is
probably a struct of data that is going
to be local to a particular thread um so
it looks like the way that he's probably
uh you know sharing data between threads
is he's not really sharing data between
threads every thread has its own kind of
local struct of of data and it probably
gets dispatched to do a particular task
now the way that i assume this is
working
is he's probably and i haven't looked at
the code yet this is just a guess but i
assume he's got regions of the image
that he's processing from these
individual threads so maybe like a
little uh kind of uh square that like a
tile that is going to be kind of each
thread is going to be but there's seven
threads that doesn't really
work with tiles anyway we'll see
um and then each thread can kind of just
focus in on just one region of the image
and that way they're never working on
the same the same kind of image the same
portion of the image the same memory at
the same time so there's no real kind of
need to synchronize those threads which
is good because as soon as you have
things like spin locks and various other
synchronization like weightings
behaviors then obviously they're kind of
bottlenecks for slowing down
multi-threaded uh programming okay so
yeah so this is basically just us kind
of uh setting that up that up we
actually allocate
a bunch of
i guess color data here which is going
to probably be
the destination
so image data is
destructive image data which
let's see if we can quickly find that
here we go so image data dot h
so we have color a point
a an unsigned point
a float point that's actually a double
and uh destructive image data which i
guess has a size which are two ins
uh a buffer size element size and then
the color pointer data which is probably
the destination so that's actually kind
of the image that we're creating that we
then later display on the screen so
that's our rendering target basically
like a frame buffer
um
and then uh okay sure okay okay so we go
through the image our size which image
does size that's the whole image i think
why and then next developer p thread oh
okay
okay so it looks like he split it up
into columns
um and that would explain why there's a
start column and an end column so he's
probably rendering seven columns and and
they're kind of each thread is just
focusing on its column that it's
rendering so the image is split into
seven columns and then each thread is
rendering a column of the image okay
that's interesting now he did um ask me
to talk about the cpu cache a bit so i
will mention immediately that this this
kind of already doesn't sit well with me
i don't know how the algorithm works
whatsoever maybe it has to be like this
but you almost never want to deal with
columns going down columns is always
almost always worse than going across
rows right because assuming the way he's
storing this image
is uh you know in the way that i guess
opengl will expect it when it's done
anyway is the fact that like zero zero
is probably like the bottom left or the
top left probably usually the bottom
left and then like
the memory kind of advances like as the
pixels advance
in them in their memory position they're
going horizontally so that's kind of
friendly in terms of like the cpu cache
because as you're kind of looping
through that that rendering that you're
doing you're
you're kind of uh working on memory that
is contiguous it's kind of right next to
each other and that's a lot more cash
friendly than if you were for example
going down rows so i'm not i'm not sure
if you're actually doing that but if you
are
that's probably a big performance boost
that you'd get if you were doing it
horizontally rather than vertically
um but again i don't know how the
algorithm works maybe it has to go
vertically maybe there's
i don't know maybe it has to be like
that because i did see kind of a lot of
vertical lines in that image so it might
just be the way it has to be okay
there's a demo mode which we can turn
off i guess uh if demo mode then it just
moves the camera around by itself oh
otherwise we have some keys here so
scale x distance so f3 f4
scale x okay so we can change the scale
i'm just going to see if we can actually
do this so left right i will move the
camera position
i and a
that's a a and d is the looking angle i
and o is the height
up and down is the camera position left
and right it's also the camera position
x
okay so let's go ahead and turn demo
mode off
and then let's go ahead and
oops let's make it again
and then i'll just do bin slash main dot
bin
oh cool okay
yeah so see like the way that it's
like there are a lot of i don't like
that it's like shimmering
but there are it looks like it's just
made up of vertical lines of color so i
maybe the algorithm has to be like that
we can rotate which looks absolutely
awful with all the shimmering
it looks fine when it stops but for some
reason when it's moving it's
it's a bit weird and then what was it f1
f2 for wall that
that's trippy so that's playing with
like the perspective which is where you
really start to see that it's actually a
2d image
um in case there was there ever any
doubt and then okay so this is like the
draw distance which increases the fps if
we make it shorter okay and what else
was that i and o
and then d and a was just to rotate i
think that's it cool
right
oh what did i press
k
k l
okay to cycle through the different maps
wow that's pretty cool
yeah this is really nice let's take a
look at the actual rendering code
so this is all just setting up like
camera stuff i'm not gonna bother with
that
um okay so here's okay so this is the
main loop right yeah while so this is
inside the main loop so
when we get past all of this kind of
input handling stuff the first thing we
do is create a whole bunch of threads
okay that's the first thing i want to
tell you is
is not ideal you shouldn't be creating
threads every
like frame
what you should use is either a thread
pull or in this case since you actually
have
seven regions on the screen that you're
rendering
just create the threads as part of your
program create function
and that's it like you don't have to you
can just keep them running right so you
can set up like a while loop inside the
threads that is actually constantly
rendering and then some basic
synchronization to make sure that
everything's done and kind of like what
you're doing here you're waiting for the
thread to finish execution
and then you're um at that point you're
drawing everything else so each thread
has to finish its
execution and then i guess you're doing
sprite draw and then you're moving on so
you're blocking the main thread to make
sure that all the threads are done
and then once they're done you're moving
on that's fine but again because it's
like you're creating threads like this
isn't this isn't very cheap so i would
definitely do something like that if you
really like the kind of you don't want
to have like each thread be its own
constantly running thread with
synchronization because that i will
admit that will make it slightly more
complex than this kind of threading
model but just use a thread pull right
so you have a pool of threads when it's
done it gets returned to the pool and
then you can obtain a new thread to do
your actual work which is this i am
render voxel space slice function right
so that's something that i would do just
to kind of uh avoid the penalty of
creating threads every creating like
seven threads every frame um and then
waiting for them to join and stuff like
that um but yeah so each thread gets
dispatched to this i'm render voxel
space slice which i'm assuming is the
actual voxel rendering code we'll take a
look at that in a minute and then we
have sprite draw with the image data so
i actually want to see what this does
which
let's see
program.c
core sprite draw and sprite does it
there's a lot of these sprite draw okay
so put pixel so this stuff will actually
uh like blit the pixel into place into a
target buffer i guess um but where is it
gonna put it
where is this function
that might be part of like some other
library or something
i'm gonna image data
image data let's see here we go now here
it is
right this dot data
dot position okay so it puts it into
image data so we're just copying into
image data again each thread would have
its own region that it copies into so
they're not really
overlapping or there's nothing
uh
bad i guess going on there and then i'm
assuming once you have that
how are you getting that texture on
screen
so let's see so
sprite draw just does that
um and then
[Music]
printf graphic swap buffers
what does that do
aha okay well yeah misleading function
name i had a feeling it was in here um
because that's like the that's like the
next thing really but you can see we
bind the texture texture sub image 2d
which gets that image data from the cpu
to the gpu now and then we just issue a
like we draw um
like six uh vertices here which makes up
a quad uh you could make this just a
single triangle or something like that
but
um it just simply does like a quad
and then that fragment shader i think
that we
very briefly saw just basically samples
from that texture and then draws the
pixels onto the screen so that's kind of
how the rendering side of it works again
there is just an image data that gets
uploaded to the gpu every frame and
that's what we're kind of doing it'd be
kind of interesting to move this into a
compute shader or into like a fragment
shader
that would be a cool little exercise as
well but that being said we've come to
the moment of truth where we actually
take a look at this voxel kind of
algorithm so let's take a look at this
and maybe we can actually visualize um
in some way how the algorithm is working
because i think that'll be cool so
render voxel space slides so we take in
a bunch of parameters those were those
kind of p thread info parameters that we
take in here not sure why you had to
make it a void pointer considering you
obviously know the type
but sure
we have angle just a bunch of other
things sine cosine
whatever
we go through all this determine the max
height i guess i am clear which probably
clears the image data and then while
that okay so we render it in depth
slices and then we go through
um all the image data
again i'm not really familiar with this
algorithm i'm not going to dwell on it
too much i'm just looking at the actual
code and then we go through uh
x okay so right so we're going through
horizontally but then we're drawing
vertical lines into the buffer yeah so
this is what i was talking about with
the whole cpu cache situation
um
we're kind of going through max height
and we're putting star dot y to i so
this loop that actually draws the pixels
is going like it's very possible that i
mean to be fed like the the image size
isn't very big because it looks so low
resolution but it could be like a a
cache miss every time you
go down that row because obviously the
memory that you're drawing to is far
apart it's not close together like it
would be if you were you know doing
start x equals i so that's just
something to kind of think about um in
terms of
uh like how your memory is laid out and
how you're rendering to it
uh but okay and then we basically draw
vertical lines um which draw some kind
of yeah vertical line so that could also
be difficult to do if you switch it to
horizontal i'm not sure how you would do
that
but um that seems to be uh what you're
doing here and then that's the position
color maps map index okay so we get like
the position from
the map where's the there's probably
like a height sample that we do here
height map color from height maps again
i'm trying to be very brief here
um and then we draw a vertical line
based on
uh
like the color that we've read in
and then i guess the distance is also
going to be height on screen which comes
from the height map but then also
probably to do with how far away it is
which is the z value
yeah so height on screen you can see it
gets divided by z times like the scale
which we played with again during a run
time so stuff is further away obviously
smaller and closer to the center of the
screen which is our vanishing point so
yeah pretty pretty cool
again really interesting to see the fact
that i guess this does in fact uh get
dispatched on multiple threads and we're
actually operating on separate regions
of this image the actual code is
identical for each region it's just the
coordinates are offset and so it's kind
of easy to multi-thread this is how like
ray tracers and offline renderers like
to do things as well they have these
tiles on the screen and then like each
cpu core or even better each like gpu
processing unit as well uh if you're
rendering on the gpu instead of the cpu
can actually be dispatched to handle
like a particular region of the image
and do the calculations for them that's
also how just normal hardware
accelerated rendering works so we have
like groups of pixels in the fragment
shader that get processed at the same
time because they're all kind of
independent of each other uh and that's
like a huge optimization to having to
kind of do it in a serial fashion where
you go through every like pixel one by
one that's like a disaster
um because again the pixels aren't
really dependent on each other so it's
really easy to kind of uh i guess
multi-thread this so you could you could
definitely like seven threads is fine
again cpus aren't really massive
parallel machines so i think that it
would be really cool for you to take
this project and move it to the gpu
because that would be really cool and
that would just be
way way way better performing so that's
kind of my little challenge for you but
anyway let's see if we can visualize the
rendering because that would be i think
it would be cool to actually see the
threads being drawn so for that to
happen we'll have to slow down the
rendering so let's see what we can do
with the main loop so my idea is just to
basically have like a max iteration that
we can draw to so if i do like um
[Music]
let's do this
uh
but then we can't really synchronize it
between threads very easily can we
or maybe we can
so let's just make like a static end s
max iteration
so i'm going to be a little bit loose
with my synchronization because i don't
really care about like this isn't this
is just to test things um but if we make
that what i want to do is basically tell
it
oh no no i don't have to okay this is
what i'll do so i've got my so what this
variable is going to be max iteration is
as as many pixels or as it's not going
to be directly pixels but as many
iterations of the rendering that we're
allowing right so in other words like we
can tell it hey i only want you to draw
five lines this frame and then next
frame it'll be six lines and then seven
frames sorry seven lines so we'll
actually kind of
see the image being created over time
um and so to do that what i'll do is
let's just do it here for now all i'm
going to do is i'm going to say if and
we're going to be only reading this
variable here so it's going to be fine
across threads if
iteration which we'll keep track of up
here
iteration equals zero
if iteration
uh is like
if iteration uh is greater than max
iteration then we're going to break
right
and then we'll also increment iteration
so we have a max iteration which will
just basically increment every frame and
then we'll uh prevent it from doing any
further rendering if it gets to the
point of like our max desired iteration
so over here after we join all the
threads i'm going to increment max
iteration this might be too slow might
be too fast i'm not sure we might have
to add like a little thread sleep as
well which we could do to slow it down
but let's go ahead and i'll do make and
bin slash main dot bin and let's see if
we can visualize the kind of threads
doing their rendering okay
okay cool so that was very very fast
but you kind of saw how it was being
drawn from the front to the back
and that's obviously thanks to the fact
that this while loop goes from z which
is like one all the way off into the
distance but let's also add like a
little thread sleep so i think it's like
i think we can use like you sleep which
is in microseconds
so let's leave for like 10 milliseconds
uh
and see if that kind of slows us down a
little bit
okay
yeah so you can see that there it still
kind of looks like it's okay we really
need to separate the threads i think and
we can do that by um
by telling it to
uh
draw to show how it's actually doing the
actual pixel rendering so i'll move this
into here as well
and then this is probably going to be
very slow now
because it's going to break
it's going to break a whole lot easier
so maybe we'll reduce the sleeping let's
see if we can get rid of sleeping
entirely
okay cool so we had to wait a while but
here it is and you can see how those
vertical lines are all being drawn kind
of from left to right but then they're
actually ending
at a certain point right
like we're drawing left to right but
then
it stops and they're all also happening
kind of at the same time which is pretty
cool if we wait a little bit longer we
can see more of it being drawn and you
can see how
you can kind of see how the screen's
divided into these seven regions and
then we're kind of going through and
drawing these vertical lines which might
not be very deep i guess but some of
them are a little bit higher than others
so that's pretty cool i love visualizing
algorithms like this and seeing like how
they actually work
um and like what order they do things in
uh it's i think it's really kind of
educational and it's also just fun to
look at
[Music]
so yeah pretty cool little project i
definitely enjoy this code review you
can also take a look at this if you like
because i've left a link in the
description below to this repository
hope you guys enjoyed this little code
review leave your thoughts in the
comment section below as always for this
series you can send in your code to
cherno review gmail.com there'll be a
not a link but like the email address
will be in the description along with
the instructions of what you need to do
if you want to send in your code for me
to take a look at but otherwise i hope
you guys enjoyed don't forget to hit the
like button if you did and check out
skillshare using the link in description
below as well see you guys later goodbye
do
[Music]
you